i want to give a shout out to lorenzo j
i do agree with them
he said pat you and so boy of the year
have not spoken about tony shea
and his passing it's been reported that
covet depression played a role in his
death
right covert depression is playing a
role
uh uh in his death okay now and cnbc i
think cnbc or msnbc i sent you to link
high we have talked about
internally but not here though not here
though if you want to bring that up just
guy just cr you'd like writing a
paragraph buddy okay there you go okay
tony cnbc press uh control minus minus a
couple times
control control okay there you go bring
it down a little bit uh no no the other
way yeah the other way tony shay's last
month's
uh a tragic reminder of how covet
isolation can worsen mental health
here's how to help so
here's a guy that's in isolation he
likes to be around people
okay and there's a lot of weird stories
that came out
about you know i immediately said rest
in peace because i remember reading this
book
delivering happiness ridiculous book i
made it a book of the month everybody to
read because there's a lot of value in
it
see that's worth a half a billion
dollars it's crazy no will
no will no will yeah yeah this guy's
worth a half a billion dollars no will
translation isolated drank a lot tried
different drugs
okay yeah i i i wanted to see where you
were going with this because
tragic number one but being isolated
because of covid was not the cause of
his death
this guy was doing some weird [ __ ] man
but wait a minute let me ask you a
question i mean you're going to
being isolated is not the cause of death
you don't think people are having
suicidal this
you know conversations what i said i'm
talking about him specifically but let
me ask you a question
yes here's a question for you here's a
question for you how many people do you
ever seen that one movie where
there's i wish i could know what the
movie is some of you guys may remember
what movie it is
this guy who this girl who comes to work
every day she's suicidal
every day she's suicidal she comes to
work
and she goes and does her thing doesn't
talk to anybody and then one day
somebody says oh your hair looks so good
today
her level of susa you know it went lower
it's a movie i can't remember the movie
she would go to work and she was ready
to kill herself and she was just like so
sick of life and all this other stuff
dude sometimes coming to work and you're
around people you're like hey what's up
johnny what's up bobby how you doing
how's everything
right take that away from people to not
have interaction with human we
need interaction dude you're talking
about
you want to increase my immunity okay
put me around some people a little bit
for me to be able to talk to people
what about that anxiety that depression
that also goes in effect
i love that point and and i'll i'll give
you kudos to that and then i'll get back
to tony shea i think aristotle once said
we are
social animals we are social like people
need
to be interacting with other humans
that's just a
basis of life i mean shout out to what
we do here every day
i spoke to my buddy who's a huge like
the biggest trump supporter ever he's
out in uh pittsburgh
shout out to scumbag joe he was shocked
shocked that we come to an office and
work he's like you guys
go to work every day what envious yeah
well i mean he's
yeah maybe um and he's still getting
over the fact that
that trump hasn't won but he was shocked
he's like you hold on what i was
facetiming with him yesterday
but he's uh he can't believe we're going
to work
but texas is very normal yes and red
states
but uh florida as well yeah i got to
tell you guys going back and forth
it's just like entering two different
universes from texas to california
really
it totally is but with tony shea yeah
and everything you talked about being so
social interacting having to be like hey
your hair looks nice
pat you're putting your hair doesn't
look as curly today it looks nice you
know like
getting compliments hey what's up cool
fast sick best tom
like people crave that need that need
appreciation need recognition no doubt
so covet has had some effects especially
on businesses no doubt no doubt no doubt
with tony shea specifically and i'm a
fan of his even jeff bezos
who doesn't post a lot on instagram i
don't know if you follow bezos on
instagram
he posted a picture of tony shea like
respect yeah but he was doing some weird
stuff he got down to i think a hundred
pounds
he was seeing how long he could go
without eating or urinating well adam
did you see he has this diet where it
was called the alphabet diet where one
day you only eat foods that start with
an a
the next day it's only b they literally
said when you got down to wxyz
he wasn't eating at all crazy that he
lost sick amount of food with the next
but the the
the saddest thing here and he was doing
all this weird stuff
he was sort of a pyromaniac he had a
fascination with fire he was playing
with fire
he barricaded himself in a house the
house caught on fire choked on smoke
whatever
happened happened but extreme example
um versus what actual normal people
don't give isolation any credit to that
you don't give isolation five percent
credit but push them over
that's not what i said i'm saying
isolation is a
real thing you talked about how people
are social creatures and aristotle
you know said that we are social animals
and we need to interact yeah but that
doesn't mean that you go down to a
hundred pounds
you do an alphabet diet and you get
become a pirate are you asking for me to
do an endorsement of alphabet diet
because we're not doing it
is this another one of those shout outs
looking for sponsors no no we're not
doing alphabet diets not on
valuetainment no
no no i'm not i'm not disagreeing with
you but by the way he's saying he was
doing some weird even in the book
delivering happiness he talks about the
kind of parties he put together he's
a party guy he likes the party he's been
a lot of drugs enablers all around him
too no one that could tell him to stop
sure but the biggest thing and you might
want to weigh in on this
he recently uh well he sold his company
to amazon
however many years ago for a billion
dollars but he recently stepped down as
the ceo of
zappos he had all this money money can't
buy happiness he was fine
maybe sort of lost his purpose he was
exploring with life and the meaning of
life and kind of
going down a wrong path um and you know
he he sort of lost his baby
i don't i don't know bro i think you
know you need uh
yesterday we got some bad news okay and
i'm going to say publicly so everybody
hears this i don't have to say
you know uh uh to a bunch of different
places so
uh uh two weeks ago we announced we're
having twins thanksgiving we announced
we're having two ones we went to the
doctor doctors like we have to see you
guys asap yesterday we want to do the
ultrasound one of the babies is dead
right shut up you have one baby is uh
what's body was right there in the
ultrasound the other baby you see uh
fully grown the baby died like
exactly when we announced that
thanksgiving the baby died okay so
babies stayed same size the other one is
grown okay
so you know i'm saying this i'm not
saying this you know but what i'm trying
to tell you is this
we go to the doctor yesterday we come
back here jennifer comes
she's in her office morale goes talks to
her
there's a relationship there's somebody
that you have somebody to talk to
i am grateful for the people were around
because you have someone to say
dude i just had a bad day today dude
things are not going right oh good man
it's all gonna be fine
and the spirit around you can lift you
up
what do you what do you do so for us
believe me listen it's been a very weird
week for us it's not been the easiest
week for us it's been a little bit weird
because a lot of things are going on in
and uh uh you know i've been
talking to jen as we're going through
this how about the people that have
things like that happen that have no
one to talk to to go sit there and you
know just how you doing man you want to
go have lunch you want to go have coffee
you want to take a walk are you okay are
you good did even somebody ask you are
you okay
is everything all right yeah i'm good
that release
of a man to man women to women face to
face
it is liberating you need it
people need it so many of them don't
have it you have to have somebody to
talk to
and that zoom is not giving you the
personal touch by the way
zoom is not the personal time zoom is
great technology you know
it's changed obviously he became the
business manager the person business
person of the year
with time magazine for what he did with
uh uh i think he was the guy that became
the business person of the year
for starting for doing what he did with
zoom but people need the personal touch
and i feel a guy like tony shea just
needed somebody to tell him bro you got
to slow your roll and you just sometimes
need to hear that over
and over and over and over again until
somebody says at the right when you say
you know what
that was soothing that was comforting
you're comfortable with it right
so yeah look um i feel bad for people
that are fully isolated away from
everybody yeah well condolences man
yeah i i appreciate again for sure
really sorry to hear that
you know uh the the new normal this is
becoming a new normal who defines that
this is normal
you know i look at you know i think
people are going to grow to hate zoom i
i think people are going to go
to think of zoom as a negative school
my kids have been on the zoom school for
nine months so it's gonna be a year in
march and there's no hope for them going
back to school
and it's just it's so unhealthy i mean
you've literally given up a year of your
life
i mean and there's no end in sight it's
it's it's depressing
it's terrible have you ever seen how
single babies babies who are uh
one one child family how different they
are than those who have a sibling
you ever you ever studied you ever
noticed the trend with people that are
by themselves
by themselves well look at the guy like
robin williams it's very famous only
child said
your child sent them you know it's a
little bit like man think about being
the only child it's not
the you know like when we when we i
intentionally when we bought a dog i
bought two of them you got two kids
you got two pit bulls right i don't know
about getting one dog
you know it's like the guy needs company
you know you know your siblings i don't
know about one child
it's tough and by the way some people
make a decision to do that and some of
them can't do it so
not judging anybody that your help is
not alive some people are just glad and
thankful that they just had one
but look that whole one child you know
story is
you know the kid can only tell mom and
dad you can't relate to
he has to have somebody on a daily basis
to relate to a kid somebody at least
that's
two three four five years his age where
there's some kind of non-isolation
you're working from home all by yourself
bro i don't know
i don't know if this is i don't know if
we know the side effects of this long
term that's all i'm saying
we're holding a meeting right and my
guys are saying well what do we do with
this there's a meeting i'm supposed to
be in san antonio this weekend the
conversation
was they're doing it at this place a
real nice place like tahoe
beautiful home we did an event two years
ago they had it locked and everything
was set up
and then they get the notice i'm
supposed to be in lake tahoe this friday
for an event and i'm supposed to be in
lake town next week for christmas
so we get the award this week for lake
tahoe okay what do we do
i said people need to be around people
figure out a way to go to a state
that allows you to be around other
people yeah follow the six feet the
whole nine
so guess what state they're doing their
event in texas
guess what city san antonio hotel
founded opened it up
great they're going to follow the
guidelines they'll be in the same room
together because people need
company and i'm doing a kickoff meeting
beginning of the year january i think a
sunday monday kickoff meeting right
after new year's i'm holding a kickoff
meeting
i've been doing this for a long time
this year we're doing it live here
in texas dallas at a hotel we're going
to follow the six feet guideline
but we're doing it because people need
to be around other
people i think that shows leadership for
these companies that say hey
you know what here's the last thing i'll
say you look at california which is shut
down everything new york which is on the
verge of shutdown
everything it's not working it's not
like that is resulting in these numbers
radically going down so you look at this
objectively and you're saying okay
they're putting all these harsh
restrictions on you
you can't interact you can't go to work
you can't go to school you can't go to
church
and yet it's not moving the needle one
bit
well your kids are all in school right
now they are
yes they're on school now uh two of them
were not
they had to shut it down for a couple
weeks but now they're all going to
school
yeah but the high school at the school
is shut down still fully yeah the high
shutdown high school so the younger the
kid the younger kids a little bit more
these kids need to be around other kids
i mean imagine dude
i can't even tell you like i remember
when my son was like
60 days into it he's at home isolation
it's like he was a loser one day i mean
he was like completely losing them one
day yeah
tycho he was like man i got to be what's
going on daddy what do we do wrong cause
a daddy you didn't do anything wrong
this regulation i want you to be around
your friends so i was
they were coming to the office they were
happy to see you guys they were coming
here like oh what's up you know walking
around just like seeing human beings oh
there are people out there
that kind of but not a lot of people can
do that can you bring your kids to work
yeah not a lot of people then you
compound it but there's no other
releases you can't go to the park you
can't work out you can't go to the gym
you can't play in your organized sports
leagues it's terrible
um yeah my i have a nephew he's uh
nine years old and my sis my sister's my
sister's son that's like my little best
friend
they've only had one kid and i make a
point to make sure that i'm hanging out
with that guy i'm bringing him around
all of my best friend's kids like listen
you got to interact here yeah cause i
saw that he was becoming a little like
that's my stuff don't touch it i'm like
listen buddy like i'll house all your
[ __ ]
i don't i don't think like we're not
playing that game we're not playing the
selfish kid game you're going to learn
how to share
you're going to learn how to lose
properly you know like i'm not going to
let you win
only child syndrome is a real thing and
you got to teach them i'm going to give
the complete opposite somebody just gave
five bucks and they said my son is an
only child but he loves the online
school for the flexibility and now he
spends more time with his friends
there are some stories like that you
know to be complete opposite of what
we're talking about
and then nova toure just gave 10 bucks
and i have an online business i chill
and work from home
all the time barely have friends haven't
been outside in literally months i'm one
of the crazy
few who can live like this hahaha there
are people that can live like
introverts there are people that can
live like that you know pat i think adam
could be a good dad that was
seriously i think i think adam is i
i think adam will make a wonderful dad
adam will make a wonderful dad but you
know
when it comes down to marriage man you
you fall in love emotionally but you
gotta marry logically
you fall in love emotionally but you
gotta marry logically it's a very it's
my biggest problem
yeah i know you want to get married very
emotional
there's no logic going in dating the
wrong women
well listen if you're looking on tinder
you're going to just constantly fall in
love emotionally
it's just a bunch of emotions
we went there